just there's an unstoppable threat in
the position pretty much rook takes
bishop next move black's rook taking the
white bishop with check will actually
unleash a discover check uh discovered
attack sorry against white's queen as
well the queens they're on the same
diagonal and white's queen at the very
least is gonna fall and there is no
square for the king to escape from the
discover check yeah because
in case of king d2 let's say pinning
winning the black's queen back but then
bishop takes e3 not true this time yeah
bishop takes also wins but
think everything wins here in this
position uh for magnus white's bishop is
simply falling on the next move uh black
would capture it with his bishop or rook
and that's just came over and okay it
does run away with her king
again plenty of winning moves here but
just okay i was going to say either
bishop takes bishop or a check first and
this is very effective magnus wins the
white bishop and
okay resigns a bishop down in a hopeless
position all right
that is a very nice win for magnus cross